What?
You gonna pick me up?
Wait, how do you do that?
Wait, that was your name, right?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa!
We're like cheerleaders, I just...
How do you... Oh my gosh, how do you do that?
Yo!
Wow!
We all have different glasses!
Yeah!
Nice glasses.
Thank you, nice hat.
You look like Cartman from...
You look like Simon.
We should go on a whole camping trip like this sometimes.
It's nice.
Yeah!
Beach ball!
Oh, wait, there's something here.
There's a to-do list.
You guys, our camping trip is over!
Are you okay?
Oh, you're dead.
Oh, what happened?
What happened?
Hey, roll me.
Oh, oh!
You try now, Phoebe.
You eat the meat.
I try?
Okay, meat tag.
Oh.
Oh, I'm dizzy.
Do not eat babies.
Hey, how do we wake you up, Phoebe?
Wake up.
I'm trying to revive you.
Wait, Vicky, can you revive her?
Uh-oh.
Press clutch.
What's that mean?
Oh, Phoebe!
It is manual!
I'm lying to!
Can you drive Vanyulmento?
No!
I've attempted...
Park.
Okay!
Um...
Toggle engine, oh.
Oh!
Go home!
Maybe you gotta come in!
Oh, well I'm still wet, I'm still attacked.
Let me understand.
Hold on, let's see.
What happens if we drive on while you're attacked?
I'm kind of...
Me too, I'm kind of curious too.
Okay.
All right, run, run far that way.
I'm pulling you
away.
All right, you really are stuck.
Oh my god, I'm stuck, stuck.
Here, you can go to the winch.
Okay, I'll sit right where you sit.
I'll reset the winch.
Vicky?
What?
Oh, oh, oh, jeez.
I'm all over this.
I'm all over now.
Wait.
Our grill!
I did my best.
Oh, my God.
What happened?
What the heck?
What did you guys do?
You guys, I was not here for this.
Okay, yeah, you're right.
You were with me.
Vicky, what did you do?
Oh, our grill.
Are the wind...
Are the windows smashed?
No.
I've never seen the world so trashed.
Oh, oopsie.
Okay, hold up.
Oh, my God.
That's not going to cause it to set on fire, is it?
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I'm pushing the car.
I'm pushing it.
I think I'm superhuman.
Let's go.
This is Densetsu Power.
Wait, how do you push?
F.
Oh, nice, nice.
Hey!
Hey, hey, up!
It's okay, Vicky.
It was your first time driving manual.
I think I did pretty good for my first time driving.
Yeah.
I wasn't there to see how this happened, but I'm sure you
were just fine.
Wait.
This is not your fault at all.
There was a goblin on the road and you tried to avoid
hitting him.
Okay, good.
Okay.
Nice.
We're going into one, baby.
Okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm reversing?
You can't straighten out again.
All I saw was Vicky get hit by the car and go flying and
then the game was over.
She was the vehicle this whole time.
manual now, everybody.
Oh, we got music?
Is it okay to play the music?
Oh.
I know how to do this now.
Nice.
This is a bomb.
Uh, uh, uh.
Uh.
Hey.
I'm in control.
Uh.
I know how to drive me.
Manual.
Watch out for falling, Rock!
We're falling!
Don't worry about it!
Yes, Mr. You're doing great, you're doing amazing!
Yes!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my bad.
What the heck?
That
I just...
Okay, you guys, I just up our vehicles value by like
$200,000.
Okay, like...
Yeah, to be fair, probably true.
It's for stargazing and smelling the fresh air.
Yeah!
We don't need to go anywhere.
Oh, what?
Let's go burgle them.
What?
I mean...
Yeah, I'm stealing their scrap.
Whoa!
Ah!
That's not a stick!
Oh my god!
Wait, can we eat it?
Can we eat it?
Oh!
Ow!
What the hell?
Is she dead?
Oh, I got the antidote!
I got the antidote!
Thanks, guys.
Wait, can you take...
Oh, I'm... I don't... Wait.
Let's see if there's a weapon around here.
I got some bear spray.
Maybe that'll work.
Oh, maybe.
Oh my god, that's shaking!
That's
everyone!
Why don't they move though?
Like once they, oh they do kind of, they switch a little
bit.
Wait, I want to see the burger.
Wait, Phoebe became a burger?
Yeah, you just take a, take one of the meat patties and then
you put it on the grill.
Here, watch this.
It's like popcorn.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh,
hold on.
Try it.
All right.
Fry me up.
Baby?
Uh...
Oh, man.
The cheek version.
Yeah.
My butts.
My
butts.
My butts valley has a huge ass.
Let's go!
We found some bear spray.
Here, let me shower you, Phoebe.
Ooh.
Oh, I just...
Oh, can I have some bear spray as well, please?
Oh.
I think it was a one-time use.
Cool.
Okay, so the bears come for me then.
Thank you guys.
Are you okay?
Did it work?
Maybe the bear spray makes the bears like you more.
I don't know.
It doesn't feel like...
Do I smell nice?
Do I...
Hmm, smells like beer and cigarettes.
Where are you going?
Okay,
no, no, no, good parking, good parking.
Okay, cool.
We're gonna watch some stuff.
What's happening?
What?
Oh, it's a bear!
The bear is here!
It's a bear!
On that
note!
Alright, how about whoever loses rock paper scissors has to
drive?
Okay!
Wait, how do you do it?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I got it.
Press eggs and then you choose Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh, we all did different things.
What does that mean?
We all chose different things.
Wait.
Whoa.
If there's that stuff like that for us now, Tiz, I'm the
paper.
Wait.
What does that mean?
Wait, we all did a different choice.
It's a three-way.
Yeah, I did scissors.
Well, I don't know what that means, guys.
So, um, okay.
That is a bit scary.
Yeah, I'm going to floor it.
I'm going to floor it.
Oh, Minto, we trust.
In Minto, we trust.
Yes, Minto, yes.
Yes, Minto, we trust.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
All my bones, all my bones are broken.
All them were broken.
Oh, man, did you guys put on your seat belts or what?
There's gonna be a way to get down here.
Yeah, there is, there is, there is.
potentially like it's deep but uh there ain't no mountain i
can't climb if it goes up it must come down kills babe it's
there wait
what my i became a bag of bones wait what you're hitting the
cube yeah see me dead in the back sorry i didn't see that
but your name's all the way up there oh is it oh there you
go oh thank you oh why am I infinitely repaired oh my god
you guys see this I'm in it we broke the game I died doing
what I loved oh my god I am infinitely repaired it's my
trouble I can't stop journal she's dorking it she can't stop
It's the only thing that can make you feel something.
It's the only way I can feel anything.
Just lay down in the bed to get some nice rest, you know?
But I'll still be jerking in the bed.
Wait, wait, I know how we can do this.
Paper beats rock.
Oh, you're right, hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
Maybe if I rock paper, scissors, it...
Oh, it actually fixed you!
It fixed you!
I fixed it!
Oh my gosh!
Aw, man.
I thought I would be a chronic joker forever, but I was
not...
It's an addiction, and it's very serious.
It's very serious.
I didn't even have to go to rehab.
Guys, I don't think I should drive anymore.
I'm so glad that...
Hi.
Watch this.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm attaching to a tree.
You can do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Up here.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Winch it.
Taking the six back.
Sorry.
I mean, you can.
Yeah, you can do this.
Would you like to?
You want to try?
You should try.
I think you should try.
Yeah.
Okay.
Who's having the best right here?
We believe in you.
Okay, I didn't understand how you switch gears or anything.
It's Q.
You hold it.
And then you go to number one.
Ah, so you go to number one.
Got it.
Am I sitting?
I should be sitting.
When the car is straining to keep up the speed, then you can
go to...
Hold it.
I'll go push you.
Oh, let's make you drive!
Oh?
Oh!
When
is it?
Me too!
Phoebe, do you want to come see the problem?
So see tree here?
Yes.
And see tree here.
How did you do this?
Guys, I told you I shouldn't have been driving!
Hold on, hold on.
Vicky, it's okay.
I'll take over for you.
We're gonna try something.
I think I think that's for the best.
I think that should have probably been the case from the
beginning I'm just gonna have a beer and sit down We're
gonna use the winch.
It's gonna be Okay, a cheeky little side winch Cheeky little
side winch Cheeky nando's a cheeky winch She's my side
winch.
She's my side winch My winch on the side
very nice thing to say about me okay all right i'm in oh
who is the bear spray where's the bear where's the bear he's
behind here he's at the he's at the bear is at our rear oh
my god someone repair the repair while we're alive jump off
the thing and go get him
spray them come here come Come here, come back,
come back!
Who am I hitting?
Me and die!
You're like, no, you killed me!
You're still alive, aren't you?
You can make it, Vee-Bee!
You can go over the bridge!
Oh, Vee-Bee!
You can make it.
I'm gonna prepare for it.
Just line it up, line it up.
Here, I'll help you.
Take your time.
Okay.
Okay, you can do...
Vicky, you have the controller?
You have the controller?
Guys?
Yeah?
I can get in!
Look out of the bad, look out of the bad, and then down, and
that's where I am.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, I see you down there.
It's okay, I'm inside.
I'm inside.
Oh, you are too.
Inside?
Yeah, I'm inside.
guys go get to a checkpoint bring me back to worry about me
hold on we will we will get you there's burgers down there
yes burgers down here wow i can only pick up one thing vicky
i don't know you shouldn't have told me that
can you drop me right in front of me i can see them oh no i
can see someone it's me thank you for coming to save me I
can't go down anymore.
I can't go down anymore.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I'm gonna try backing up the car a little bit.
Okay, okay.
I'll try backing up the car.
Wait, I don't know about that.
I don't know about that.
I'll try to be careful.
Can you see me?
Oh, my Lord.
Okay.
You look majestic.
You look like a beautiful bird.
Flying on the wind.
She was a fairy.
A fairy.
There's some buggies over there too if you want them.
Wait, me!
Me!
What is happening?
Chat, you're gonna have to describe it to me.
Oh, I could have just...
Hi, baby.
Why don't you just call yourself burgers.exe?
Oh, hi.
Oh, well, welcome back.
Oh, oh.
Oh, disgusting.
You can park And then Reverse You want me to line you up
Yeah
Alright Pull forward Should I just pull forward?
Yeah Okay Absolute taste for Phoebe the driver Here you go
Okay You can keep going Yeah you're good here You're good
Okay Good Yeah you're good You're good You're good You're
good A little too Oh wow.
A little tear.
Uh, you're good.
Okay.
You're good?
Oh wow.
Oh man, get back up there.
Keep going.
That was so terrifying.
Okay.
Oh.
Just a little closer.
A little closer.
Okay.
Hang on.
Oh, that was so close.
Here's a cinnamon roll.
Come on, come, come, just to give me a little taste mark.
We might have to winch up.
Winch might just have to drive up this thing.
Yeah, we got to winch up, baby.
Oh my God.
I'm pushing.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Lovely.
Keep going, keep going.
I'll keep going.
Lovely.
I'm okay!
You're okay, you're okay!
Oh!
Maybe just floor it.
Oh, there's like a tiny little ram.
Wait, hold on, I'll get out and I'll direct you.
Ah!
Thank you.
Whoa!
What is it?
It might be a bear.
Um, do we have any more spray?
Run over.
We floor it.
Oh.
That's a mood.
Wait, why did he jump?
You guys.
All right, now.
One.
Two.
Okay.
Now four.
I think you can't.
Four.
Now back to one, back to one, back to one.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
I think we should drink one last cold one together,
everybody.
Come on.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, grab one.
Whatever you have.
chug it.
Woo-hoo!
Chug it!
Kampai, everybody!
Kampai!
Yes!
Woo-hoo-hoo!
Kampai!
Thank you, everyone!
It is I, your Yurka-i princess, Victoria Roman.
I hope you guys enjoyed our RV adventures.
I will never touch a steering wheel again.
Ugh.
As for why I'm here by myself, well, this month is special.
For our Patreon channel, fan club artist this month is ARQ!
Who's ARQ?
What?
You don't know ARQ?
Impossible!
ARQ is an official artist for the IDW, publishers of Sonic's
comic series.
He's done all sorts of lovely covers for them, and so to
have him draw us is a dream come true.
He's drawn up a beautiful postcard of the three of us,
complete with a sausage roll, Obaka, very British indeed.
He also created three super cute grandma stickers of the
three of us.
Minto's classic.
It's pink.
Phoebe's never give up.
And my wife, Michael, put that down.
That's part of my private collection.
Ahem.
Anyway, depending on your tier, you get different merch
items monthly.
Each month we pick a new artist to draw us and design
stickers.
Then they get sent to you alongside the Chekis, which are
personalized polaroids from us.
The Chekis, postcards, and stickers for this month will only
be available in February.
the more you can.
There's worldwide shipping too, so don't worry about where
you are.
The fan club's the best place to directly support us, so
we're really looking forward to having you be a part of it.
Plus, members of the club will have exclusive pre-sale
access to any group shows we do, as well as special roles in
the official gencenter.exe discord.
As for what's coming up this month, Mint's first ever 3D
solo live from Minto with Love is happening this week on the
13th.
Oh, I'm so excited!
Dreaming tickets are available now!
So go support Minto!
Thank you guys so much for all your support, and thank you
very much again to ARQ for the lovely, lovely art.
You truly made my dreams come true.
Shadow, my love, I'll be with you soon.
Ta-ta for now, Denchies!